Beyond the Palm trees in the luxury of
this five-star hotel and others across
Los Angeles Harvey Weinstein ruined
lives
the former film producer was found
guilty of rape second conviction after
he was sent to jail in New York two
years ago four women all known as Jane
doad to protect their anonymity took the
stand with similar stories each though
uniquely devastating the first a model
and actor was bent over a sink and raped
I wanted to die she said I remember how
he was looking in the mirror and he was
telling me to look at him I've never
seen a big guy like that naked testified
Jane Doe too I was really frail and he
was a really big man
Survivor Rowena Chu was a former
assistant to Weinstein she says he
assaulted her at the Venice Film
Festival it's a pretty terrifying
experience uh you know being a
a rabbit in a cage with a tiger wouldn't
go amiss I suppose I feel like you have
very little power obviously it's five
years now since the first allegations
against Weinstein were made public
breaking a generation's long culture of
silence and beginning the me too era
it's a movement which has spread to
workplaces around the world
although the jury couldn't reach a
unanimous guilty verdict on all claims
these dark secrets now brought into the
light will ensure Harvey Weinstein is
never released from prison the Croatia
Sky News